hello everyone how are you guys doing
hope everything is
fine wherever you are this is uh
grandmaster's
choice welcome to this lecture um
what are we gonna do today well i'm
gonna show you the best king match
ever in chess history one of my favorite
games
this happened between short nigel short
great player from england he actually
fought for the world championship title
and
this game he was facing giant man
and i think this game happened in the
netherlands in some
city called tilburg it's a small small
city in the in the south of
the netherlands so see already a lot of
people
in the chat so as usual
you guys can give me some suggestions
i'll be asking you some questions
this way the lecture will be more
interactive
all right and after this class uh we're
gonna
we're gonna show uh one of the games um
from the u.s championship one of the
most important games actually because it
corresponds to the last round
well the ninth round and
it happens between wesley saw and
jefferson so we'll be here for a couple
of hours
and hope you guys enjoy this lecture
okay so let's uh let's start so nigel
short
decided to play e4 um black plays
knight f6 the alekhine the archine
defense right
so basically uh black is concealing the
center because after e5
black is gonna have to move the knights
like two or three times in the opening
and something very difficult to explain
for beginners right because we always
tell them
like they should only move minor pieces
once in the opening right
so this is hyper modern chess basically
you can see the center then you strike
in the center and then you put pressure
on the center with the
pawns uh later or bishops uh
from far away right so for example the
groom trail is also a hyper modern
opening right
and uh stuff like that yeah
no it's not the french game so e5 here
of course you can play knight c3 but the
main line is e5 i mean we can
gain more space in the center and then
kick this knight to n6 why not to go for
for e5 right
so here knight d5 of course this is the
bad square for the knight don't go to g8
or h5 or g4 of course you just blunted
the knight but knight d5
and the knight comes to the center so
here d4
i also like this move knight c3 i have
employed myself this move in couple of
uh
classical chess games the idea is that
after knight takes e3 you want to
recapture with this
d-pawn and then in the future you want
to go even long castle so it's a pretty
aggressive line against the alakan
so what's up jose luis gaston
gascon juan david prince of darkness
hope everything is fine
okay so d4 here and now black
strikes in the center with d6 and here
nigel short went for knight a3 of course
maybe the most natural move is c4 and
this is actually the main line
and after knight b6 you can take her d6
or you can go for the four
pawns attack which is a very aggressive
response
against the the alakan right basically
after black
takes an e5 you wanna capture of course
with the f pawn
because if you catch her with the d-pawn
then queen takes the one and actually
black is much better but the idea is
just to
you know to play knight f3 knight c3
bishop e3
and then you know it's a pretty uh you
know interesting way to reply against
the alakan
right so not a three um black here
went for g6 going for the final kettle
system
black wants to go sure castle in this
position with the bishop on g7
and then again putting pressure on e5
black can also try this d take c5
and then white's idea is not to capture
with the d-pawn but instead knight takes
e5
then i want to ask you guys um
what happens if black goes knight d7
in this position because it looks
natural right you want to kick this
knight from e5
i mean probably the the the the main
move in this position is just
e6 but i want to ask you guys what
happens if uh black plays knight d7 will
you take a d7
will you go back to f3 and then try to
go
c4 or what's your move here this
position
we are warming ma where where yeah
warming up sorry
that's right so knight f7 here just wins
the game because after king takes f7
queen h5
the king is forced to go to e6 you know
he's dancing south side in the middle of
the war it's not
a very good idea and now i don't know
there are many interesting ways here
to play with the white pieces for
example the first move that comes to my
mind
is c4 right
because now you know you can't actually
i mean you can't play something like
knight b6 d5
and then this skin is going to d6 and
then i don't know there are so many ways
here to finish the game
right so
so knight d7 is not a good move in this
position
okay let's go back to the game black
continued with g6 and now
uh white played bishop c4 attacking this
knight on
d5 and then the weakest square on the on
the king side is
actually f7 right so that's why the
bishop on c4 is
fantastically placed so black went
knight b6
in this position and then bishop b3
bishop f7 is not working
in this position casted after knight tx
f7
knight g5 black can play something like
king g8 and then after queen s3 which is
actually a threatening checkmate in one
move on f7
black can just play kine8 and then it
covers the f7 square
right so there's no problem for black
here then
at the end of the day you're gonna kick
this knight from g5 and then black is
gonna be extremely happy in this
position with the psap so that's why
after knight b6 white went bishop b3
i mean it's not a very good idea just to
go to e2 or something the bishop
is much better place on this diagonal as
as we said right
okay so greetings from astana what's up
blue
everything fine so bishop b3 and now
bishop g7 and what do you think is
black's thread right
now so for example what happens if i
just play h3 in this position which is
maybe a natural move to to our eyes
because
bishop g4 could be an option for black
just pinning the knight on f3 putting a
lot of pressure
on the knight or f3 but actually h3 is
not a very good move in this position
what do you play here with the black
pieces
so guys we are again in another lockdown
in spain
well it changes from region to region
but now
for example in the place where i am
which is ibiza it's an island
in the balearic islands so you can't go
out between the 10 p.m
and 6 a.m
so you know it's crazy everywhere
nowadays right
so what do you play with the black
pieces come on
prasanna give me your move give me your
candidate's move
d takes e5 right this is the that's
right this is the best move here in the
position because if now
white takes with the knight actually you
can even take an e5 and then queen takes
d1 and then this looks perfectly fine
for black yeah you're gonna put pressure
on the e5 pawn with knight c6 sorry no
knight c5 not even superman conduct can
go there
knight c6 and then bishop f5 then long
castle and then this skin is going to
suffer a little bit right
and it's even worse if you take with the
pawn on the on the on e5 because now
after queen takes d1
i mean black didn't even have to give up
the bishop
so basically uh black is fine in this
position right well black is actually
better
so um
yeah black wants to be in the engine
with in these types of positions but i
don't see
er we need material that's right of
course i mean it's uh
i mean we're in move number seven yeah
if black is winning material
then white should have done something
really really bad
so that's why how do we stop this well
there are different ways for example
sure castle
and in the game nigel short played queen
e2 but i want to ask you one question so
now
is it possible to go bishop g4 in this
position i mean in this kind of a hyper
modern
openings as i told you you can see the
center but then you put a lot of
pressure on the center with moves like
bishop g
g7 knight c6 bishop g4 but then
what happens if black plays bishop g4 in
this position
that's right so forcing moves all the
time you should be paying attention to
forcing moves
and after bishop g4 bishop f7 is
actually winning this is a very well
known trick in this position right
because now bishop f7 king f7 and now
knight g5
check and then this bishop on g4 is
actually unprotected and then
white is completely winning in this
position we're just a pawn
up then the light squares are extremely
weak so
life is great right okay so that's why
i mean i want to explain you basically
every move so every move
there is a reason behind every move in
the opening right so that's why i think
you know uh we can learn a lot for
trying to
to to see why these players with this
move or this move in the opening and not
just go like
first 50 moves we don't explain anything
because it's just theory yeah so the
theory there's a reason behind every
move in theory right
so our man
ym is saying you can't even play e6
first loss
alone so after g4 e6 well i'm not so
sure because now f takes e6
and i mean you're not winning any pawn
right in this position well i think
white is better but i mean you don't win
any material
but okay so sure castle in this position
so now black is covering
f7 and therefore
uh well uh one of black ideas could be
played bishop g4 in the next move
actually nigel sure didn't stop this
well sorry queen e2
knight c6 was the giant move not sure
castle
and then here shark castle from
nigel short again if bishop g4 then we
have the same trick
in the in this position
so bishop f7 sorry is a nice trick and
then knight g5 so that's why in this
position black went for
short castle and now you're gonna tell
me
one move for white in this position
what do we play now because now after
sure castle
black is actually able to play bishop g4
so somebody's saying queen e4 well i
like this attacking ideas you want to
regroup the queen bring the queen to h4
but i don't think this is the best
way to play because you know first you
should continue
development this is a very you know
usual thing to do like you first develop
minor pieces
and then try to attack this is too
direct i will say for example bishop f5
here queen h4 probably this is your plan
and then i guess i can take on e5 even
and then
actually this one is just hanging so
there's too much pressure in e5 and d
first that's why
you first have to develop some pieces
right
knight d2 connect the knights that's
very nice idea but i guess now bishop g4
is pretty annoying
well maybe not so annoying because i
can't just go queen e3
but i think the the the pieces in in
this way are not very well coordinated
so
yeah bishop f4 also an interesting idea
but i guess
you know i can try to do the same stuff
with bishop g4 and actually i'm
threatening to take on f3 and then
on e5 so what do we play
h3 yeah that's right this is the move
that nigel short went for so this is the
most
natural move in this position we cover
g4 and then we forget about this bishop
on c8 and actually the bishop on c8
uh doesn't have too many good squirts
connect the knights connected yeah
connect the knights
yeah somebody is saying can we go for e6
in this position
well i'm not so sure i think black can
uh
react in several ways in this position
but i like d5 now
because now if you take on f7 i just
take with the rook
and uh i'm putting pressure on d4
and then if you protect d4 right now
then bishop g4 comes
uh with real pressure against the knight
on f3 actually
you're striking with e4 in in in the
next move right and then the bishop is
uh is not doing anything with this pawn
on g5 so that's why i think
e6 could be very tempted right but uh
i would uh i wouldn't go for this you
know one has to be extremely
sure before going e6 in this kind of
positions yeah
so d5 and i think black's better so
bishop f4 attempted to defend e5 though
bishop f4 bishop g5
rookie one looks nasty but it it finds
defended
yeah bishop f4 it's a natural move but i
guess bishop g4 is again
pretty pretty annoying right because you
are aiming to take on e5 then on f3 and
then e5 could be hanging so
that's why h3 first and then you forget
about this c8 bishop and then you
can continue developing your pieces as
you said with bishop f4
then knight c3 or knight d2
and at this point john t monk went for
a5 just uh
you know the the the threat is very
trivial actually black wants to
trap this bishop so how can we react
against this
a5 move and there are actually two
different ways or even four ways to
react against a
a5 then i want to ask you what move
would you play in this position and
there are actually
subtle differences that i want to point
out in at this moment so
a4 a4 is an option
a4 is an option it has a drawback that
some point b4 could be weak but it's not
really true
because uh we can get this knight by
playing c3
i will go c3 prince of darkness is
saying
so basically there i mean there are four
options yeah we go knight c3 we go
a3 well next three is not even possible
right because of a4
sorry guys so now white has to go bishop
c4 and then you just grab the bishop and
then you get the bishop where
life is great again so basically three
options
or even four yeah you can play c4 c3 a3
and a4
so for example if you play c3
i guess now i can just take an e5 and
then play
something like b a4 or even bishop f5
looks good
followed by a4 so
not so sure about this c3 but it's not
the big mistake
or anything but you know after a4 this
bishop is forced to go
from this diagonal you know this
diagonal was the best iona so the idea
is to keep that bishop
just attacking f7 right and from c2 is
basically doing
not so much i mean now i can just
centralize my queen for example
and after rook d1 probably i can just go
to e6
i don't know but i just don't like c3 in
this position
now i want to ask you what do you play
a3 or a4
and yeah c4 i mean doesn't look very
good right
because now i mean you blocked your own
diagonal so basically
yeah this is not very good
so a3 or a4 well i want to try to
explain you
the differences between the two moves
and it's actually very subtle
it's not easy at all so the best move is
a4
but i want to explain you why so a3
now black plays a4 d takes a
sorry bishop a2 d takes e5 dtx e5 now
whenever you're suffering from lack of
space it's interesting to exchange
some minor pieces so for example knight
d4 makes a lot of sense in this position
because now after knight takes d4 queen
64 now black managed to
uh to to exchange a pair of knights
which is
better for black as i told you and now
you're putting pressure on e5
and it's going to be tough for uh white
to protect the e pawn because now there
is a fantastic move in this
position
[Music]
so what do you play with black right now
actually a3 is a little bit worse than
e4 and there is a precise move
right now that explains everything come
on guys
try to be creative in this position
it's not a very common move that you see
in the middle games
so
what do we play here
by the way guys are you following the
the u.s champion you can follow here in
the in the in the channel with fantastic
commentary
from jennifer shahadeh just sir sir juan
and maurice ashley
rook d8 well rook d8 i mean
i'm not sure i just played knight c3 for
example
and then i can try some e6
yeah rook a5 that's right ernst rook a5
and then there is a lot of pressure on
e5 basically
i don't say a way to protect this pawn
on e5 sorry guys
my flip-flop just uh
escaped so now i guess the only move is
e6 but
even after taking on e6 we should take
c6 even
f takes e6 this looks very good for
black
because if you take an e6 just go keen
h8 and then
f2 is under attack you're gonna develop
easily with bishop e3 because
the b2 pawn is just hanging then this
rook is joining the party
you can't even double rooks on the f5 so
yeah so i wouldn't go for a3 but the
reason is this rook a5 which is
very very interesting now i think my
software collapsed a little bit
which is not a very good news for us
let's see what i can do here you know
this happens
from time to time okay now it's working
so
a3 not the best move in this position
because of this line but instead
nigel sheriff went for a4 he forgets
about these a4 ideas for black
not rook a5 anymore and then the bishop
on three on b3 is
fantastically placed and then b4 is not
weak
because our pawn is still on c2 right
okay guys so this uh at this moment
black went d takes e5 dtx e5
and then what would you play here with
the black pieces well
you have different options the problem
is this guy on c8
i mean you never go bishop b6 right
because you ruined your phone structure
so on d7
it's not so well placed on f5
there are always g4 ideas in this
position i mean not now but for example
knight c3 you continue development with
bishop f4
rkd1 and then you see that black has
real troubles
i mean if we talk about space
okay so what do we play here with black
pieces
i mean not an easy position right
so for example e6 looks natural because
i mean you protect this diagonal but at
the same time you weakened
the dark squares so young timmon went
for this
for this move knight d4 same idea as we
just saw before so the idea is to
exchange a pair of knights and then put
some pressure on e5
so white is forced to take on d4 queen
takes d4
and now basically the only move to
protect the e5 pawn is rookie one
again you go e6 in this position i guess
black can just take an e6 and then we're
same kind of position that we just
analyzed so queen e6
kin h8 and then you take on e7 i guess
black has full compensation for the for
the pawn
and after queen c7 what do you play here
with black
can't white take on c7
kin h8 well now we'll analyze king h8
but i mean here there are some tactic uh
tactical problems yeah
rookie one that's a good move also rook
takes f2
looks very nice as well rook f2 rook
takes rookie one
kin h1 and now now what
not not queen f2 well i mean probably
it's winning two
but just bishop e5 and then we just grab
the queen right
so rookie one rook f2 both both moves
work so
this is why e6 again is not
a very good move and then the bishop on
g7 is well restricted with this pawn on
e5
so if we managed to keep this pawn on e5
and then we managed to develop
all our queen side we could be much
better in this position
because the bishop of g7 is not working
the our bishop on b3 is a very good
piece
yeah so rookie one this is what white
played in this position
and now again it's not an easy position
for black
because you're gonna put more pressure
on e5 the only move to put pressure is
knight d7 and now of course
e6 makes much more sense and uh
yeah what do we play bishop f5 uh
bishop f5 i mean just uh for example
knight d
true to go knight f3 and then bishop f4
in the game giant demon went for e6
which is compromising a little bit the
position because now this bishop is
it's not gonna be active anymore and
then black will try to to put this
bishop probably in this diagonal a8
h1 and still doesn't know how probably
maybe bishop g7 and bishop
c6 during the future some b6 followed by
bishop b7
what do you think of hikaru performance
in the current u.s championship
nobody expected this right because i
mean chicago has been playing
so well in in the last online
tournaments you know
uh before all this pandemic i mean it
looked like
he was not in his best shape i mean in
classical tournaments
so but in online chess it looks like he
was the only
player available to to to fight against
magnus right
and this is actually what happened in
the sun
magnus tour tournaments and uh i
remember some epic finals between uh
ikaru nakamura and magnus carlsen i
think they finished
four three i mean four matches one my
magnus and three matches won my car
it was just a fantastic show you know
but uh i didn't expect this of course
and i'm also very impressed by
uh wesley saw's performance you know he
makes
it makes looks uh to play so easy
so definitely carry with four out of
nine it's not a very common thing
but okay so e6 and now
it's why to move in this position come
on guys give me some more what would you
play here in this position you want to
play c3 you want to develop these pieces
i don't know bishop g5
knight c3 or knight d2 what's your
favorite move in this position
until tell me why
that was an epic match do you think it's
just about tournament for nakadam yeah i
think so i mean naka is super strong
in online in rapid and i mean in
everything yeah
but uh we talk about rabbit and blitz
chess and online probably it's just
uh the best after magnus at this in my
opinion
but we'll see knight a3 well i don't
like this move
knight e3 93 yeah you want to go to b5 i
guess
i can just develop my bishop to d7 after
knight b5 i guess i can just go queen c5
and then again it's not easy for you to
play bishop b3 but definitely
an interesting idea but this could solve
black trouble because
at one point black can just take on b5
and again
black's suffering from lack of space so
i think
to trade peace is not a very good idea
right
knight c3 knight a3 well i think the
most
natural move here is it's just knight d2
this is what the niger shot did because
you want to put this knight on f3 and
then just win a tempo i also like knight
c3 knight a3 is very interesting
but knight d2 makes a lot of sense too
right the knight comes to f3 we protect
we super protect e5 and then we are
ready to develop finally
the c1 bishop
so here black went knight d5 and i
understand john stieman's idea he wants
to go b6
and bishop b7 if black manages to go
like this then
his position will be completely fine and
then one important thing to remark is
that after moves like c4
then b4 is actually a way square so
that's why the knight on d5 is kind of
well played and what's up sidant
and here yeah next move is pretty
obvious for all of us which is knight f3
and here
black went queen c5
okay so we have developed the knight
from b1 to f3 which is a clear
improvement in our position
and now it's time to build our attack
because we have like
have you read the book from vladimir
vukovic the art of attack
it's a very nice book it's actually one
of the bibles uh
of attacking chess and he says
you should have some preconditions
before you
start an attack here we fulfill the
preconditions i would say
because uh we have a nice uh pawn on e5
which is uh
well uh supporting f6 and also
avoiding some kinscapes in the future
and we hope we have more space and it's
not clear how black is going to create
contemplate on the center or on the key
inside so that's why we are
in good shape to start an attack in the
key inside
yeah so bring the pieces uh
yeah all your pieces are developed being
one of the conditions that patrick
dailey
daily say and you know black has also
some weaknesses
which are the dark squares and then we
think okay
pepe so what do we do well if we manage
to trade these two guys
this would be fantastic for us because
the dark squares will be extremely
weak right so
yeah that's a good day i don't know for
the bishop the a1 rook is not
playing yet but it will be so basically
i mean
whenever i see this position i think i
want to eliminate these two bishops the
bishop on
g7 and the bishop on c1 right so
then what do we do h4 h5
idea yeah i mean that idea is always
interesting but mainly
when there is a rook on h1 with the king
of g1 i mean
i'm not sure if that helps to match your
attack h4
h5 because after h6 black just retreats
the bishop to h8
and with the rook and hy
sorry on h1 makes a lot of sense this is
actually one of the techniques in the
attack you open the h
file and then you know you attack with
your heavy pieces
launch long range attack pieces the
queens and rook
yeah so bishop g5 that's uh definitely
an option
right but the thing is after h6 i don't
know where you're going with the bishop
well probably bishop d2 so bishop g5 is
yes a natural move but i like the move
that
nigel sure did he went for queen e4 as
mr school is saying centralizing the
queen and maybe moving towards the key
inside later on
yes exactly so queen e4 it is rather
simple you want to continue with bishop
h4 and then bishop h6
just eliminating the fiancee bishop
which is a
a monster right okay
so here giant man goes for queen b4
of course his idea is to trade queens
what should we do in this position
should we trade queens no
don't trade queens in this position
because i mean we are trying to attack
right so we should keep the queens in
the board so how do we play right now
how do we play no trading that's right
knight d4 one of your ideas
you know and whenever i see so many
pieces like kind of unprotected
unprotected story i get really scared
but it's an option it's an option but i
think you don't stop trading
you don't avoid trading with this move
because i got c5 right here
and uh knight b5 could take c4 employee
that's close
that's close to a balanced position
right
um c4 c4
is actually not possible because queen
takes v3 i mean
the first move that comes to our mind is
bishop takes before just winning a pump
right i mean we didn't talk about this
move but i think
it's not you know the best choice in
this position because after e takes d5
queen takes d5 this bishop goes back to
life and now black has
does one does one i mean black has one
of those positions
where he's enjoying the bishop and then
therefore he's got some compensation
after bishop b6 his bishops are very
good so
that's why i wouldn't go for a bishop g5
yeah yeah c4 is not possible because you
drop the bishop on b3 so
we eliminate that option so we don't
have
too many options again so i mean we can
play queen e2 which is
a very decent move you want to later
continue with bishop d2
and then kick the queen from there maybe
then going back to e4
but the mode from nigel shirt is bishop
c4
which could look very strange because
now after knight b6 we have to reinforce
with b3 otherwise
again black is managing to trade queens
but then we have to realize that our
bishop on c1 can also join the party
by a3 and now black has this rook on f8
and the queen on b4 and then
this way the bishop on a3 is actually
creating a lot of troubles so bishop c4
was played by nigel shirt now knight b6
front teeman well now we are forced
actually to play b3 otherwise
after bishop f1 or something like this
we just did something very stupid now
queen takes e4
and i even prefer black in this position
i just go bishop d7 bishop c6 put
pressure on a4
and black has nothing to worry about in
this position
yeah deep i wouldn't have spotted bishop
c4 because of principles
you're right patrick it's not a very
common move but it's very interesting
because now
after b3 i mean the bishop is coming to
a3 so black is going to have to waste
more tempi stopping this this kind of
ideas
so now of course black to come c4 how do
we recapture in c4
i mean i if i see somebody saying i
check with the queen i just
i just closed this class queen takes e4
we deserve to go to prison it would take
on c4 with
with the queen yeah now black would be
much better because black has the bishop
a better structure and black is more
handsome
so b take c4 and
now it's black stone you're gonna give
me a move in this position and then you
have to stop bishop a3
so how do we do this
how do we do this
um by the way guys do you like soccer
you know who is santiago solari he was a
player from real madrid and uh
he is actually an ambassador for real
madrid football club
right now these days he was actually the
dt the coach of
madrid two years ago and we are
doing something with the with the real
madrid foundation
sunday charity chess event and actually
i
i was yesterday with solari and he was
playing a game against magnus carlsen
blindfold
was so such a nice experience
yeah rook rook e8
i think these are the two all the
options in this position right
i mean queen e7 again bishop a3 so
rookie 8 was played by john timon now
after bishop a3 you can't just go
queen takes a4 ball because i don't see
any discover move
that wins the game so yeah rook e8
stopping bishop
a3 and now probably black's next move is
bishop d7 united to go bishop
c6 so again we have to think about
prophylaxis also b6 is an interesting
move
so if we continue with the attack let's
say queen h4 in this position which
was our first idea then black can play
b6 and now if black goes sorry white
goes bishop h6 which is part of our plan
then i think black can even take on h6
and then queen f8 coming to
defensive tasks and i think black's fine
here because
next move is bishop b7 you have a
fantastic bishop
the queen protects h7 in case of of need
so i like black's position here
so what do we play again bishop a
frequent takes a4
so i think it's just for now it's good
to maintain
the queen on e4 because it's actually
stopping b6
yeah rook d1 for white and patrick says
that's why i wanted to go
rook d8 in this position and then occupy
the default the problem with rook d8 is
that now bishop g5 comes with a tampon
that there's not only the plan
of going bishop h6 but also the plan of
going bishop
f6 in this position and then try to do
the same thing just eliminate this guy
from g7 and then the dark squares will
suffer a lot
so that's why maybe it's a little bit
more natural rookie 8 in this position
right and uh rook
a3 very interesting move we'll talk
about that move later
yeah rook a3 but now i think black plays
bishop d7
because black is not only aiming to go
b6 and b and b7 but bishop d7 i would
say
if black brings the bishop to f to c6 to
this diagonal then
black is fine so how do we stop this
prophylaxis prophylaxis
yes rook d1 that's right so supendu
rook d1 you stop rook d7 and then b6 is
not possible right now
okay so queen c5 was played by
jean tima it's not easy to move here
with the black pieces
and now actually the move that somebody
suggested right there in the chat that
our friend
school suggested it's very interesting
rook a3 in order to go
rook a to d3 and then it's not
easy how black continues development
but instead nigel's shot said you know
what i'm just gonna go queen h4
in this position of course his idea is
just to go bishop h6
now basically there is one only move for
black in this position to improve
its position do you see this move
so how to play with black right now
because now bishop d7 is not possible i
mean yeah b6 that's right
basics the best move in the position and
now
you know we have different options for
example
we can play bishop h6 which is part of
the plan but then we realized
that again after the move bishop h6
queen 86 now queen f8 this is a nice
defensive resource
so how do we deflect the queen from the
from the f8 square you see how many
subtleties the game has you know
it's actually very interesting to to go
deep in this game
i've seen this game analyzed in uh in
other places like they just take 10
minutes you know and then i couldn't
understand because it's just
so interesting there are so many
subtleties you know
that's right yeah h5 looks uh
suicidal as you say h5 in this position
well it's
actually it's it's it's it's wide turn
yeah so bishop
e3 that's right bishop a3 is also an
idea but now after queen c6 this bishop
basically
is doing nothing in this diagonal i mean
i mean we had the idea of trading these
two guys with
from a3 is this is just impossible well
you could try some bishop e7 but i just
don't believe in that
it's too many tempi so that's why bishop
e3 you deflect the queen from f8 and now
you are ready to go
bishop h6 in the next move in the game
black continued with queen c6
but if black just plays something like
queen e7 of course we just trade and
then we bring
the rook to the eighth file forcing
bishop f8 and now
bishop h6 this looks completely crushing
well you see the move here too
with material you want to go rook t1
what do you want to play here in this
position after bishop b7
so why to move and win
in this position rook a d1 well rook
take the one
is not it's actually a blunder and i
think black's better after this move
rook e8 so no
there is a winning move here just much
much easier
to spot like 4c moves just compute all
captures and then you'll realize how
we win in this position pretty easy
come on guys yeah that's right mario
mario
that's right bishop f8 rook d8 the rook
on e7 is just hanging
so again forcing moves all the time i
know
i insist on this every day but this is
the way to go
so queen c6 and now bishop h6 and you
see
right now why he went he didn't go
bishop h6 straight away because
queen f8 was a really nice resource
of course black cannot take right down
h6 if blood takes on h6 queen takes h6
there is no way to stop knight g5 in the
next move
well you could try something like bishop
b7 saying you know what if you got
knight g5 then
i take on g2 with a checkmate but i mean
there are
so many interesting ways to play here i
mean the easiest one is just to play
rook g4
with the idea of rook h4 in the next
move right
so that's why bishop 86 is not possible
i mean whenever you are playing
with the fiancato bishop you should try
to keep this bishop so
there is again only one more move for
black
in this position which is or even rook
d5 could
could be working in that position not so
sure
rook d5 was working just i'm just
curious right now so
queen c6 bishop here and uh
bishop takes queen takes bishop b7 rook
d5
probably is probably working yeah pretty
amazing yeah
queen d7 and then here i think the point
is you don't take with a queen but you
take with the knight and then out of six
all right pretty nice so here
yeah that's right tc bishop h8 we keep
the bishop i mean if the bishop is gone
there's no way to protect that game
right
and now this position is much better for
for white yeah
how
bishop h8 i refuse to play bishop h8 on
principle because every time i do i lose
yeah but this this i mean this was the
only choice yeah in this position
and now how do we proceed
with the white pieces it's not clear
yeah probably you will love to go
something like knight g5 but then after
b7 f3
i mean something like queen c5 key in h1
queen e5
and then you are not on time actually to
create some troubles on h7
so knight g5 i would say it's not
working
okay so here nigel short went for rook
g8 which makes a lot of sense
actually now bishop b7 only move you
don't want to check on d8 of course
because there's checkmate background
problems so bishop b7
and now rook a to d1
well so now black is a really difficult
situation for example if rook takes d8
rook takes the eight and let's say black
plays speech of a6 saying you know what
you cannot actually make any progress
there is a killing blow here this
position for what
come on guys let's finish john tayman
let's end this whole
yeah queen e7 that's right great
so this is why black played here bishop
g7 going back you know now
offering the trade of those bishops and
now
my question is would you take a g7 would
you play a different move
queen e7 again oh queen e7
queen e7 i just take on h6
and actually the root on e8 is protected
by these two pieces and then you're
attacking with two
so it's not working actually black is
winning so
let's be really careful in this position
how should we proceed
yeah if you play bishop h8 and bishop g7
something's gone real bro
i i agree with you patrick
bishop g7 bishop g7
is actually a bad move not because of
thing king takes c7 because now after
queen f6
let's say king j8 you've got rook g7 and
then
you know f7 is under attack so basically
only move this rook f8 and then boom
queen f7 followed by queen h7
but the point is black doesn't play king
g7 black takes on d8
in this position rook takes d8
rook takes d8 and now king g7
the point is after kin f6 king g8 now
you can't go rook d7
i'm probably you are a little bit better
but if you take on e8 then you lost uh
your advantage
and you go knight g5 that's made on g2
so it's not that clear probably you're
still better after something like rook
d4 but
you lost actually so much advantage in
this position
so bishop g7 not the best move
yeah rook 1 to d7 rook 1 to d7 i guess
black just you know trace everything
rook takes eight
rook takes e8 and then bishop h6 and
actually black is winning
because you have to take on e8 first
then queen h6
sorry queen e8 queen h6 and now
bishop takes set three followed by queen
takes a4 and then black is win
so still we have to be extremely careful
in this position
very cautious so what do we play then
i mean we managed to play like genius
well we didn't play
genius it was nigel's show now we want
to ruin his position
with only in two moves
teenage two this is very slow this
doesn't improve our position
and then as i told you black stretch is
to take on the end and to take on
on h6 yeah that's right hello everyone
hello everyone suggested the best move
rook a to d7
a very good move because now this rook
on a8 is doing basically nothing
um and white's threat is just to take on
g7
and then blatant queen f6 in this
position right
so i mean black is in a really difficult
situation right now
and again if black takes on h6 right now
then queen takes h6 and let's say
bishop c8 something like that you can
even take on f7 probably key in f7
and then knight g5 and then this is
going to be checkmate pretty soon
so that's why gianty man played rook f8
and here bishop takes g7 is of course
now possible kim takes g7
second phase of the attack you know in
this book
uh vladimir khabib it's bush the art of
attack he talks about
faces in the attack the first phase is
like preconditions the second phase
is you know create weaknesses
in this case we have created weaknesses
by trading
the vnk.bishops and now f6 and h6 are
extremely weak
and the third and last phase is
execution
so how do we continue well
now nigel short has all the time in the
wall and he went for rook 1 to d4
which introduces sun attacking ideas
just lifting this rook to the king side
right
at some point and actually black cannot
even move in this position there is some
sort of suit span
because these rooks are not doing
anything this rook has to protect
f7 you move this rook there is queen f6
followed by queen f7
so probably there's only one move that
comes to your mind
to kick this rook from d7 and this move
is
this move is what
[Music]
yeah bishop c8 i mean at least to me
this is the third move uh the first move
that comes to my mind
because this rook is extremely active on
d7 then
i just want to kick this rook from d7
right so bishop c8
but it's actually not possible because
of queen f6
king g8 the knob boom rook f7
and you see this rook is not working
now after rook f7 black would love to
have this bishop on b7 now rook the 8th
is just mate
so that's why in the game giant man went
first
for rook a to e8 now he wants to
continue with bishop c8 and then finally
kick this rook
because after bishop c8 now queen f6
followed by rook f7 doesn't work because
now the rook on e8 is covering d8 okay
so the game continued with queen f6
teenage king g8 and now this game is so
fantastic even the engines
don't think that the move that nature
short played is a great move
but then after some seconds thinking
it says it's just amazing idea
now there are different ways to play in
this position
how would you continue
we have almost everything yeah all black
pieces are
extremely passive black is in a kind of
sutman
this pretty weird german word
right i lived uh three years in germany
actually working as a researcher
in hamburg university in the applied
mathematics department
and then i'm still not able to pronounce
x1 correctly
okay yeah teenage too i mean
still maybe not the best idea i mean
i also like knight h4 knight h4 looks
good because now if black goes bishop c8
i think he can just take on g6
and then after pawn takes rook h4 wins
and then let's say black does nothing
with bishop c8
you can play f3 something like this and
then you are threatening knight g6
exploit
probably this was also win but then
nigel short
starts with h4 basically
his idea is just to go h586 and
checkmate
so the only way to stop this is to play
h5
right and now he starts with a
you know cow move which is king h2
that probably some of you would be
thinking okay keenan h2 is just some
sort of
past move and then we're just thinking
okay black to move and then we'll see
what he does because we have good pieces
but no
it's actually a part of a extremely
dangerous plan for black
and this is why this game is so amazing
you will see
in few moves now if bishop c8 this
didn't happen in the game
bishop c8 black loses but there is only
one good move here for white let's see
if you guys
are able to spot this move
i'm sure you guys like 30 50 percent
of the people down there in the chat
probably to just saw
the game before but probably you didn't
take
uh you didn't pay much attention to all
the mobs in the middle again and in the
opening so hopefully we will learn
something today yeah
yeah but now very beautiful king h2 we
want to bring the king to
to h6 but now you want to go king g3 in
this position are you sure 100
you bet your house on this
well now you go king g3 i just take
kin f4 this is the idea that happened in
the game the king comes to h6 but now
after
you know for example bishop c8 king g5
would just go king h7 and then
you did something ridiculous
right so
i mean this is just waiting for for for
black
so we're gonna do something against
bishop c8
rook g8 yeah rook t8 again rook d8 just
take on the eight
and uh i don't know i just play bishop
b7 and how do you continue
rook f8 f8 queen h8 kidney seven
i don't see any matching ideas down
there so note we again
we are again ruining the position
it's tough it's a tough move to make now
knight g5 you are right matan knight g5
great move on after bishop d7 rook f4
and there's no way for black to stop
knight f7
and this is just completely winning for
white let's say queen c5
knight f7 and then for example you go
let's say kin h7 you can play
queen g5 and then queen h6 and queen h8
me
so that's why not f7 if black takes an
f7 here in this position
you just take queen g6 and then you play
g3
and then if you don't believe me you can
trust the engines this is completely
winning for white
let's say queen g7 queen h5 you go king
g8 there is rook g4
you go kinetic queen h7 you can even
take and then play rook f7
taking the bishop on d7
alright guys so knight g5 was winning
maybe timon saw this and that's why he
didn't went for he didn't go sorry for
bishop c8 but instead he went for rook
c8
and now we start our dangerous plan
this is in my opinion the best skin
march
ever in chess history
king g3 now probably john team and
realize
okay now this this guy is coming to f4
g5 and h6
and there's no way to stop this because
whenever the king goes to g5 then black
tries to play
king h7 this is a whole different story
because we got a rook
on the seventh trunk and f7 is going to
be under attack
so rook e8 now from john t man probably
aiming to go bishop c8 in the next move
but now king of fours just completely
win
finally timon tried to play bishop c8
and then king g5
and jaunty mont resigned what's a pity
yeah
i would have loved to see bishop d7 king
h6 in the board and then
queen g7 you know this is a kind of a
nice
gesture when when somebody plays such a
nice game against you
you don't resign right you just wait to
your opponent to checkmate you
because here the point is next move is
king h6 and a black ghost king h7
we got different options to finish the
game but i like this one king
queen g6 now taking on g6 is actually
not possible
greetings from tunisia i played a really
nice tournament there in the beautiful
island of germa and then i'm going back
in february if this pandemic
allows it to do uh
to do commentary in english for the
tournament so kinetic and now
queen eight six king g8 and now how do
we finish the game we feel like i said
we take our monocle
and their suit you know we take some
caviar
ah jose what's up man
good to see you here yeah yeah of course
i joined you at some point i remember
in the live stream yeah yeah
keen f6 that's right you know pretty
amazing kim
and then queen g7 no way to stop mate
on g7 okay guys so one of my favorite
chess games for sure 100
and uh hope you guys enjoyed this
lecture i think we'll learn some some
quite interesting things in the opening
and in the middle game
and we saw some subtleties in the
positions
so it's been a pleasure as usual uh we
just closed this stream
and then we'll open a new one in two
minutes because we are gonna analyze the
game of the day from
the u.s championship between wesley
seoul and
jeffrey shawn again that was extremely
important because they were leading the
tournament with seven out of eight
before that game so yes big hacks
from spain just take care and stay
healthy yeah bye bye guys